we've tried the chicken factory I'm
still having like my sweaters giblet
reply beautician turns out hot wax it's
not my friend I'm running out of options
for you here Luiza
please I'll take anything this is New
York air and companionship for disabled
man do you have any experience of
caregiving um I've never done it but I'm
sure I could learn then that's going
well well this is your music lark
Nathan will talk you through world's
routines and equipment you don't have to
talk across me mother my brain isn't
paralyzed yet hi Amelia
nice to meet you and so I loved me
before you and I cried like a baby and
what film gets you blobbing the most
wait it's really silly because I've been
asked that question quite a few times
and the only one that keeps coming to my
mind I'm sure there are better ones the
only one that keeps coming to my mind is
stepmom oh that's that's it that's my
game over cry yeah wouldn't she's on the
horse and she's saying this is I just
love my mom so it's it's really ah yeah
it's very sad make me Bruce that's a
good choice I'll feel like watching that
I think and so your characters fought
some wacky fashion choices and for
someone who's so broke she managed to
afford a lot of a regular choice shoes
and yes well no I know anyway yes Harry
and what was the most impractical outfit
on set or maybe did you have a favorite
um so my favorite look was in the
library I wear these wicked dungarees in
this like Mexican jacket hmm um and then
the most impractical one was there was
just one day I just had really sleepy
shoes
we were filming outside on there were
cobbles that he just wasn't that was a
bit dangerous but yeah but just with the
costumes I know we talked about this a
lot with it being kind of how could she
afford all of these clothes but
genuinely Jill Taylor the person who
designed the whole look was would go
into second-hand shops and go into High
Street wagon bins and find like
everything it was it was really good at
shows like who knew you could get all of
this well she gave herself a budget ah
well even girl tease of clothes they
still find a minute to buy them look
exactly and so I loved how funny the
film was which is maybe what I wasn't
personally expecting and and Ewan
Patrick we're hilarious together and
when you wants a Harry Potter fan and
perhaps when you start when you met
never long
autumn in the flesh well it was yeah
definitely is a Harry Potter fan and was
just one of those funny things cuz when
you meet Matt Lewis you like that I
never long but I never buy especially in
lycra very different like yeah v-point
than I had when I watched the movie so
yeah uh he was gorgeous and Hillary was
Sophia and so even Sam Claflin mister
spent hours with each other on set by
hours and hours and I loved that you
played pranks on each other which I've
read a lot about yeah there's one of you
take it just too far well he thought I
did with the fish in his sucks I mean
that is why it is quite fine no I know
he was pushing me it was it was that I
had a time restraint
um and so yeah he cut in two and what
he's but he's then getting back at me
was pretending to be really upset
because I like no I know and I was like
no I can't handle me being upset with me
cells like no my goodness so the next
day I bought him three pairs of new
really fancy socks but that's for you
yes I'm a be forgiving and your cry face
is so on point I have the ugliest high
face ever and you are disputable did you
practice in front of the mirror no this
is the exact opposite I watched it the
first time and I was like why didn't I
practice crime before era like don't let
the ugly cry out on camera it didn't
come out beautiful and so I love that
you have a scene with Joanna Lumley and
we're like oh my god it's Patsy stone
yes yes she's amazing
yeah I was probably shaking throughout
the whole scene and every time I met her
I was like oh that's go with me yes I
mean you excited about the movie yes
yeah I'm very excited yeah and so it
will is very sarcastic in the movie and
so I've had them with very British do
you miss it when you're in America and
what else do you miss maybe uh yeah when
I cuz I don't because I still live in
England but when I am when I do booming
and stuff in America and the sarcasm is
definitely I've like tried to kind of
teach some people and it's just you're
just like never mind I'll just sarcasm
myself and but t oh look I don't wanna
be you'd wanna be on brand away yeah but
I bet seriously like I care about t
quite a lot and it just nothing tastes
the same and my final question is are
you prepared to get even more vecna's
because you look very much like you in
the film so even more recognized
down the street Oh pepper um I don't
know how you can really prepare for it
but yeah it's sort of beginning to kind
of happen a little bit and um well I
just hope they're nice oh thank you so
much it's lovely to meet you thank you
so much you too I don't want you to miss
all the things that someone else could
give you
I have become a whole new person because
of you there's something clogged you uh
pretty much here anything that makes me
want to get up in the morning wait for
me to come home